he was trying to send me a beauty
DiCaprio to meet up because I talked
about information episode how watching
Titanic changed my life showed me the
sign of humanities like Jeff's like hey
like Harvey why don't you hook up your
music
and then like Leo accordingly obviously
and then uh
no office Richard email we wanted to
meet he was at here for the UN event I
was out so we couldn't really meet how
old were you at the time yeah
they're in the range you know Leo below
25. do you know oh you know I know my
heart was broke yeah but it will go on
now do you think that Leonardo DiCaprio
could have fit on the door with Claire
Danes at the end of the Titanic higher
Danes is it Claire Danes what's her name
yeah yeah yeah yeah come on bro
even he can't understand
no no do you do you think they could
have both fit on the door together
that sounds a little communist of you to
be honest yeah everybody should live
equally yeah I mean this is to be honest
no it's because it's just so cute in the
movie
he's a heart throw yeah not now oh my
God no thank you
wait a minute wait why are you not into
it what are you not I mean no no it's
like who's the hottest guy in the world
in the world in the whole world outside
of your fiance who's the hottest guy
like the number one dude
my used to be my type was Kim Jong-un
[Laughter]
body time you know because in North
Korea that's a sign of power and it's
supposed to be thick yeah because if you
do everybody's starving like me so small
so if you're fat that means you got
money because nobody lived long enough
to get bored
so if you're old and fat more than fats
are you are very very sexy Harvey
Wednesday
so I used to love like so my fiance is
not the most fit man either so but
that's what you like that's good that
means that he's successful
like slowly more getting into fitness so
maybe okay Harry Styles you like Harry
I'm not too gay
I agree
keep on going okay
the number one man George Clooney George
No thank you
people like Joe Rogan like works
yeah okay I'm not gonna tell him at all
it was a Rock The Rock Dwayne Johnson
Dwayne The Rock Johnson oh you don't
know I thought Obama was very handsome
when he was younger no yeah
this guy right here what about that guy
yeah that's Dwayne The Rock Johnson how
tall is it
he's like oh wow okay yeah yeah I think
I can max hand The Joe Rogan Heights
okay I'll go above like six maximum six
feet is your top yeah those tall guys
they're awesome maybe if I'm on the high
heels then like I can go for six two six
two maybe maybe okay what about Brad
Pitt like people like Brad Pitt Brad
Pitt is handsome you into Brad's not
really actor what about Will Smith oh
yeah he's very yeah yeah yeah he's very
very yes he's good yeah
what do you think about Keanu who knows
it has a long hair I'm just not into
long hair in order long hair like we did
they need to get two to three inch the
mandatory for the government what is two
to three inches there hair
yeah yeah okay now
how do you feel about like man buns like
yeah
this is a Korean style is it yes yeah of
course it's known
North Korea
you know like you don't like the man bun
yeah no man bun no long hair not too
tall Not Too Tall not like six four like
not too too much with the six foot yeah
yeah no it's basketball players too much
yeah I'm friends with the anus Canter oh
yes yeah yeah yeah yeah oh my God I'm
not coming under his armpits I know yeah
yeah I know that's yeah how is Ennis oh
what okay a Jared Leto Brian Reynolds
yeah that's I mean the haircut is good
you like that yeah yeah yeah oh Johnny
come on right Johnny Depp oh Bradley
Cooper what about Bradley Cooper I mean
he's the ideal vanilla vanilla
my girlfriend okay Bradley you got to
connect I'm sure you know someone that
can get in touch with him right I can
you want me to set up a dentist as a
friend just a friend dinner just a
friend dinner
embarrass you who would you want who
would you want to play you in a movie
about your life
I don't know the actresses that much I
don't like watch that much TV I'm more
like big book person so I don't know a
lot of like who would you want to write
your story write my story yeah whoever's
good R.L Stein oh that'd be fire what's
that Goosebumps yeah he wrote like
horror books for kids yeah interesting
okay yeah it's an old version you know
the horror movies have a lower version
no they do they have a little bit lower
budget but it doesn't have to be horror
we could make it something else exactly
yeah you know like it's a drama they
made it they tried to make a movie about
my book about your book yeah yeah first
book and then they send me the writing
of the book I mean the movie and I know
like literally writing the script play
saying whenever in China that was my
Promised Land
like what the [__] is this this is not
what happened it's like this is the only
way we can make a movie about North
Korea and Hollywood today oh wow no
thank you you don't need to make a movie
it's like I'm good so I got put up the
thing because because Hollywood has has
interests in China they want China money
there's also the elderly walk so yeah
they're very woke yeah yeah this is why
I'm fighting like if you think that we
have a lot of freedom like a lot of
things we are coming watching certain
ideology is like controlling all these
institutions and it's really sad like
you have no problem making movies about
all other like hot like genocide you
know the Hotel Rwanda is fine but some
North Korean issue they cannot do that
did you see the Hotel Rwanda did you
guys see Hotel I wanna how was it yeah
it was really good movie yeah so you
want a version of that because movies
can get a message out to people that
would never consume your message
they just want story yeah and we attach
ourselves to these stories right yeah so
maybe the movie is the way
yeah if somebody has so you know it's
courage to stand up against CCP they
could but I think everybody's afraid
here everybody is terrified yeah I've
been doing this for the last seven years
begging people to do something they say
the silence is violence when it comes to
gay rights lgbtq rights PLM everything
they are fine
the slogans into you you really do of
course I mean that's that's that they're
chanting every day in the middle of the
the low light like Library they go
chanting this stuff and yeah strikes
every day it's horrible really so you
didn't like Colombia
I barely survived it I mean it was very
oppressive
barely surprised
it was very bad because it was exactly
things I was living in North Korean
classes like the most oppressive life
what is the most North Korea or going to
the University of Colombia
of course okay what about China or North
Korea
China or Columbia University
yeah so as somebody curious intellectual
is so oppressive yeah but not physically
you know yeah that is a good point so
those other places they weren't well I
guess then uh North Korea was
intellectually oppressing you as well of
course yeah in China there was just you
weren't even treated as a first physical
I was getting raped yeah I was kid look
that [__] hits when you say that to
me I'm gonna lie I'm not gonna lie like
that that is good I should have trigger
warned him yes
we're used to saying the like jokes that
involve that but when it's real that is
just fun different thing